make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
rob core let me tell you guys let me
tell you
let me tell you something man let me
tell you something y'all remember when
we did jonathan hickman's avengers and
new avengers and like i was standing up
like i got out of my seat
i got out of my seat i'm holding my
microphone in my hand right now i don't
even know if you can hear it um i i got
up
out of my seat and i was like man
man let me tell you what's up you guys
remember that do you guys remember that
when it was just like
damn uh that's what this is
guys that's what this is that
is what this is that's what this
is right that's what this is let me get
back here let me get man let me get back
in my chair
let me get back in my chair before we
start having church in this place this
this story
is not let me tell you something if god
was writing comic books right now this
is what it would look like right now
it's it's it is man it's amazing i hope
i hope y'all feel the hype i hope y'all
feel the excitement okay so so
we pick up with dylan who's now inside
of
null the symbiote god right we pick up
with dylan who's now part of null the
symbiote god and and this initially is
like like null talking to him
noel's just kind of like hey like like
don't be afraid you know all that kind
of stuff
the issue is that while null is talking
to dylan you have this third voice that
comes out of nowhere now initially my
thought was oh my god it's flash
thompson right like flash thompson is
talking to dylan which would be cool
it's not flash thompson right i'm not
gonna tell you who it is but well i will
tell you who it is i'll tell you here in
a little bit but it's not it's not flash
thompson right it's not flash thompson
so here's a crazy thing the voice is
kind of talking to him and it's like
dylan like you have to listen to me
right like you have to remain calm
and you have to listen to me now while
all that's going on you got null who's
kind of talking to this kid and saying
like calm down right like i'm not here
to hurt you
you know like like you know i understand
that you
have kind of been made to destroy me
right like that's the whole idea behind
you you know you were born into this
world you're essentially a living
symbiote
but you have been molded and you have
been crafted by the people out there on
your world to believe that you can
destroy me but understand child
i am not someone so easily destroyed
right i cannot be
undone by the heroes of earth do you
need do you need me to prove my point
i've conquered your planet i've taken
over all of your superheroes there's no
one left to stand against me there is
looks like there's nobody left to stand
against me now at the same time
this third voice says look like i'm a
friend right like i don't know how much
longer i can hold this connection
but i need you to listen to me i can get
you out of here right so this person's
obviously a friend
chiming into chiming into dylan and
trying to help him out and it's one of
these things where this person knows
something that noel doesn't right
they're like
noel made a mistake bringing you here in
his hubris and in his arrogance he made
a mistake
bringing you here right and you can use
that to your advantage you can focus and
you can basically control his powers
by using your own because if null is the
one who created the all black
and null is basically the person who
controls all the symbiotes then it makes
sense that if dylan can manipulate
symbiotes that dylan can in turn
control the symbiotes through null
because null is basically given the
ability to do so
like null has essentially put him in a
position to where he can take control of
the wheel that's basically what he's
done what he's done
and so it's kind of like okay like he
tells the voice in his head to shut up
right to just like leave him alone and
noel finally approaches him and says
like i will give you the darkness i will
give you the all-black
join me and then like and we'll burn
this world to the ground and we'll move
on into the universe and we'll conquer
everything else right and my initial
thought was oh my god dylan's gonna side
with him like oh my god because here's
the thing in the alternate reality he
did in the alternate reality venom story
he did so i was like oh my god he's
going to side with no and i was like why
in the world would he right like why
would he side with null and ultimately
like he goes to take knoll's hand
and then he's like you killed my dad and
then like immediately just like
seizes control of null and then just
starts control like like literally
freeing all the different superheroes
who were under control of the symbiotes
madeline
right like cyclops susan storm johnny
storm thor
right you like god of thunder thor he's
literally releasing all these guys now
it's causing him a great deal of anguish
and pain right because it's just
so incredibly tough to do to literally
harness the mind of a multiversal god
it's not an easy thing right i mean it
takes it takes a little more than 15
minutes of meditation you understand
what i'm saying so it's just kind of
it's kind of nuts but then he ultimately
ends up freeing doctor strange and
that's where things shift because
remember doctor strange can elevate
himself to like super strange right to
basically turn himself into a god and
that's what he does right like he takes
his staff and he's like okay
you know if noel wants to be a god if no
one wants to kind of pronounce around
here and say he's got then that's fine
then i can play at that game as well
right and then using his staff grants
himself the powers of watoum and
basically makes himself like this super
high echelon god right now from that at
that point he literally started this
this disembodied voice
starts anchoring to everybody else
through dylan right like anchoring into
human torch and thor and doctor strange
and all those guys and it's kind of like
okay
we're all initiating one giant push at
the same time
so susan storm uses her force fields
doctor strange uses his powers you've
got the human torch you got cyclops the
whole nine yards like they're literally
launching this multi-faceted attack on
null the symbiote gods and all the
forces who were there and all hell is
breaking loose
right like like absolute pandemonium is
unfolding here right
like it's going bananas and it's it's
it's abs
it's crazy right so then you have thor
and you have storm who combine their
power over the lightning and then use
that you know to basically
attack null so like all of them are
launching an attack against null at the
same time right because when they're
free like they're freed out in the real
world right like
like dylan's still inside null and
that's kind of the crazy thing is
because once null begins to kind of
recover for a second he's like do you
really believe that you can defeat me
kid like you think you've won
like how could you possibly believe that
after seeing everything that i've done
here right sure
you freed a handful of your superheroes
i've enslaved celestials right i've been
i've enslaved cosmic gods
with the power to create life who are
you guys
to stand in the face of me now this is
when this person makes their presence
known right that's when this person
makes this person know like actually
that's where i come in right they say i
don't believe we've we've been
introduced
my name is jean grey it's gene gray's
son gene gray of the x-men and i was
like
man what a wait what a person to bring
in i was like holy i was like man man
man it was it was it's crazy right like
it's it's crazy it's crazy
this whole thing right so uh at that
point she taps into the mind of null
right because remember jean grey is an
omega level telepath she can do that she
basically tapped into the mind of noel
and she's like there has to be some kind
of weakness to this guy there's got to
be
something we can exploit and jean grey's
approaching this from the perspective of
like maybe he has some kids
maybe he's like the way he is because
like he really loved a girl once she
didn't love it back you know so he took
the red pill and then got all pissy
because he believes he deserves any more
he can have any woman he wants
you know and it's like no i'm sorry no
that's not the case right when she goes
through and starts analyzing him she
starts to realize that there is no
inherent weakness to this guy not that
she can
she can determine right this guy hails
from like the darkness but then she
starts to realize the darkness existed
long before null did right like the the
darkness was there
long before he was he just somehow came
into existence
he's learned how to manipulate the
darkness he's learned how to control the
all black but it's not as though he was
the only thing there
there was a force of light that existed
out there
before he did and this force of light
faced off against null in the early days
of their existence right that null
used his power to kind of try to try to
quash this this light right this source
of light and the source of light created
its own
soldiers to face off against null but it
was still relatively new i didn't quite
know what it was actually capable of
and so it ended up spreading its forces
too thin and the result was that where
it could have defeated null instead it
ended up as a stalemate and the two of
them more or less ended up killing each
other and that's where you have like the
soldier of light versus
null crashing on on that planet that
belonged to gore the god butcher during
jason aaron's run on thor
where he takes the all black sword and
then goes forward and does his own thing
but that's where she says like like the
light it was sentient
it was alive right like it had it gave
this army
unimaginable power but it simply wasn't
enough right
and so this this this source of light
left this soldier
after you know gore took the you know
all black and left uh but like
somehow or another you know it's
basically been floating out there in the
universe
trying to find a worthy host all this
time and the whole idea behind it
finding a host
is to destroy null is to use that power
to defeat null and that's what she
realizes it's basically a symbiote
his opposite this source of light is in
effect a symbiote it
bonds itself to a house and then it
gives that host a huge amount of power
and so she's like the light it's on its
way here like it's coming here
right now but it can't get through earth
and so while jean grey's trying to try
to cope with this insanely overwhelming
amount of power
and this realization this disembodied
voice chimes in it says gene
do not worry i am here right the silver
surfer has arrived man the silver surfer
is here but the silver surfers arrived
the silver surfer shows up here and says
like i see this light trying to get into
earth
trying to bond itself to a host on earth
it cannot get through
but i can't right because it cannot it
cannot penetrate the darkness of null so
it's like i can right so literally the
silver surfer
bonds with the light and then blows a
hole through like the forces like the
atmosphere of the earth right where like
no snow
symbiotes are like covering the world
all that kind of stuff manages to blow a
hole through
no loses as [ __ ] because he's just like
he's like no
right this light comes flying in and
then when silver suffer arrives the
light leaves him and he's like oh no
you're not looking for me
okay uh then fine go and find your
chosen warrior right switch over to reed
richards and when the when you basically
pick up with this this energy source
that arrives to read richards then he's
like okay like i'm doing all these
readings i'm conducting all these
experiments
i recognize this i know this source of
life we call it
we call it the god of light because we
we didn't previously really understand
what this was but after doing all these
reading
all these energy readings i know exactly
what it is and he's just kind of like
we've been calling it by the wrong name
the actual name of this energy source
is the enigma force the enigma force man
dude because at that point it's just
kind of like like like literally it's
like finally like the the nature of the
enigma force has been completely solved
which literally
donnie cage just gave us the origin of
the enigma force right which is kind of
nuts but like
the energy source basically leaves reed
and then bonds itself to its proper host
which is eddie brock guys eddie brock
just became captain universe with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain
cliffhangers make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of rob for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you